I created this methodology to help me
become a lot more productive I
accomplished my goals one after the
other and it was never enough there's
got to be something more I had the
system to help me become super
productive but then all of a sudden I
took this system and started focusing it
on my inner life what is it that I want
and start focusing my own productivity
tools as to becoming more productive
with my own self-awareness what you're
about to hear is an interview with
writer Carol who is the inventor of the
bullet Journal method I like to describe
it as a mindfulness practice that's
disguised as a productivity system it
helps you organize what you're doing but
more importantly it helps you clarify
why you're doing what you're doing Ryder
is incredibly inspiring he has ADD which
cause various problems for him in
childhood best way I can describe it is
like trying to catch the rain so I
invented the bullet Journal method as
you know it now because I needed it
throughout his career as a web and user
interface designer he found various
different tools that he could use to
stay productive and those tools are what
eventually morphed into the bullet
Journal Journal method which is now
world famous he's written a book called
The Bullet Journal method which is New
York Times bestseller in the
conversation we talk about how he came
across the method how he discovered it
and how various people over time have
used the method to level up their own
intentionality and mindfulness and
productivity But ultimately that's what
you're trying to do as a designer is
help people create tools to remove some
kind of friction from somebody's life
and eventually what was so funny is that
the tool that I was using to organize
myself was the thing that would
ultimately become the tool that I could
share at the moment according to the
YouTube analytics 81 of you who are
watching this on YouTube have not yet
hit the Subscribe button and so if
you're for example in the now 81 of
people who are watching this on YouTube
but who are not subscribed to the
channel I would love it if you could do
so and would be awesome to get that
number down to 50 and it would be cool
to get like 50 50 sub non-sub ratio just
just for fun all right writer thank you
so much for coming on the podcast this
is this is like super super weird
coincidence so I I started bullet
journaling about a month ago and I
mentioned it in my newsletter and you
happen to read my newsletter or see my
newsletter and then you like just sort
of tweeted at me and then we got talking
and here we are in London like a few
weeks later uh like firstly thank you so
much for coming down this is going to be
it's gonna be interesting
um so like so so much stuff to talk to
you about I'd love to talk about kind of
the the origin of the bullet Journal
stuff and I guess what you're doing
these days but I guess like you know how
when you when you connect the dots
looking back how did all of this start
how did you end up the inventor of this
bullet Journal thing which probably most
people listen to this will have heard of
if not if not tried out yeah I would say
the origin story as with most things is
necessity so I grew up learning
disabilities back before the internet
where the only tool I had available to
me was pen and paper
and so I started trying to figure out
ways to be organized and productive and
I tested out everything I possibly could
and I had no resources available to me
right you can't look something up like
how do I add and that's just not there
so I started developing different
templates different approaches different
tools most of which didn't work and then
every once in a while something did and
then something more and something more
and then you do that for 20 years and
you start coming up with a system where
all these different tools start working
on top of one another
so I invented the bullet Journal method
as you know it now because I needed it
and I still need it I need it all the
time you know it's it's people always
have this misconception I'm like some
Super Hyper productive human being and
it's not the case I created this tool
because there were challenges that I had
but they were different than the ones I
thought
initially which we can get into yeah a
little bit so I guess just as as a bit
of context for people who might not have
heard about the bullet Journal method
like what is it in a nutshell and then
we can kind of explore origin story and
like the The Arc of sure yeah I like to
describe it as a mindfulness practice
that's disguised as a productivity
system so it helps you organize what
you're doing but more importantly it
helps you clarify why you're doing what
you're doing so it revolves much more
around purpose than process but it
provides both hmm that's interesting
because like I've I've been hearing
about it on the Grapevine for years I
think I first read it about read about
it on Life Hacker or something like
classic and in my mind it was just like
oh it's it's a productivity system like
I wouldn't have like the word
mindfulness would have been very low on
the list of things that I would have
used to describe it before I knew about
the thing yeah like what what what's
going on there is is that a common
common reaction that you hear it's a
common reaction because
a lot of people initially with bullet
Journal when they get to know about it
comes through social media which is
great and it's it's both a blessing and
a curse in that like a lot of people see
a bullet Journal but when you encounter
something on Instagram or Pinterest
generally speaking that audience is much
more visual so chances are their
interpretations will also focus on the
visual aspect of bullet journaling which
means that it can be very creative
interpretation or expression of bullet
Journal languages
completely unnecessary
um so a lot of people see these
incredibly decorated beautiful bullet
journals and like that's what bullet
journaling is but it can be
to me and to a lot of other people
there's a lot that's lost when you see
it online so I understand why people are
like oh it's like an artistic notebook
it can be but that's really that's
really what I try to get across with a
lot of my work it's trying to figure out
what you need it to be that's the
essence of bullet journaling it's like
trying to develop a tool based on
a very specific intention
so that's that's where I like to focus
my my all my work is what is the
intention what it what problem are you
trying to solve what goal are you trying
to accomplish and then assembling the
tools around that
if that makes sense that's where the
mindfulness comes on why do you need to
get organized what do you need to get
organized about that kind of thing I
feel like I'll productivity and process
often
um I think comes before the purpose and
that's a huge issue at least it was for
me now as I was developing this
methodology I was kind of guilty of the
same thing if I become productive then
I will accomplish my goals okay great
what happens after you accomplish your
goal
not much right not much it's like it's
done
but when you accomplish your goals in
service of something bigger whatever
that is right then all of a sudden it's
meaningful and that was the missing part
for me hmm so you grow up you grew up
with ADD what is what is that like
what is that like
um I think it's the best way I like the
best way I can describe it is like
trying to catch the rain that's that's
the best metaphor I can come up with
it's like everything seems important and
you don't know what to focus on is that
this thing is it this thing is it this
thing is it this thing so you spend all
your time trying to catch everything and
then everything falls through the cracks
so that was my challenge like trying to
catch the rain and then my
the challenge was that that's impossible
and trying to solve for that challenge
is also impossible and over over time I
guess what I started to realize
is trying to understand why you're
standing it in the first place like what
is it that you're trying to do what is
Meaningful to you and then trying to
organize around that like having a core
organizing principle before you find the
system if that makes sense
so how did you go about doing that I
guess before the system develops yeah
well sure I mean the system actually
helped me make that realization which is
interesting at first it helped me become
really focused and productive so it
accomplished those things check check
and that's also why the productivity
part of bullet Journal I think was the
thing that caught on really quickly
because as soon as people start doing it
they get things done things just start
happening
and once you start doing it for a while
something shifts you hear this often and
then it was interesting which was
something we can get into like you start
as a productivity method and then all of
a sudden something changes it's not like
how it organized something but it's like
why is this important the the the the
the question shifts you know it's like
okay I'm getting more done but I'm not
feeling any better or more accomplished
and it's like okay so why are you doing
those things like oh I don't I don't
really know it's like okay maybe that's
the question you begin with and for me
to provide a very clear example
for me I created this methodology to
help me become a lot more productive
right I accomplished my goals one after
the other I got the raise I got the
position I got the thing and it was
never enough right it's like okay maybe
it's just the next step it's the next
step and every time I took the next step
I found myself in the same place which
is like there's got to be something else
there's got to be something more
and this was very much in the the
corporate ladder and then I'm like okay
maybe the problem is that I'm working
for other people so maybe I should work
for myself and start my own company
which is something that I ended up doing
for two years me and this other guy
created this startup and this was on top
of our full-time job so we did the whole
startup thing you know like sleeping
under the desk ordering pizza all that
stuff for years and then we launched
this product
and it was successful
and it didn't matter it didn't make me
feel any better the work was great
because I love doing the work I love
design work I love figuring out problems
and all these things but when it finally
launched it didn't matter and I'm like
why don't I feel any better it's like I
thought I wanted this and I clearly I
don't so what is it that I actually want
what do I care about and all of a sudden
there's a big question mark there and I
realized that I was accomplishing other
people's goals it's like as a designer
the whole thing is to have your own
design company or to have your own
product or to be the art director and I
did all those things and all that wasn't
true right it was I've accomplished
other people's goals and realized that
it didn't mean much to me
so all of a sudden I had the system to
help me become super productive
but then all of a sudden I took the
system and started focusing it on
I would say say like my inner life right
what is it that I want and start
focusing the same tools as
my own productivity tools as to becoming
more productive with my own I guess
self-awareness
and that's where it became super
interesting noticing my own patterns
what do I respond to what do I not
respond to what what do I want more of
what do I want less of and that's where
it became really interesting okay loads
more questions on that front oh yeah
before we go there so what was the day
job and then how did that transition
into the startup like what was that Arc
sure so I um
I guess you could say that I was a ux
designer for most of my career started
and the early web website design stuff
when that wasn't common actually I mean
I'm probably dating myself here what are
we talking
um I would say early 2000s right okay
yeah so people didn't really have
personal websites but that was happening
so I started designing a lot of websites
for small businesses and then eventually
I started designing websites for bigger
and bigger businesses and then I started
designing web tools like actual apps and
that's kind of what I focused on I liked
this idea of creating systems that help
people accomplish things
and a lot of that system's thinking
actually went back into the analog space
because I found that in a very much part
of the development of bullet Journal was
like the idea of like applying a certain
set of principles to my own life and
then actually treating my life as a
product was a really interesting shift
right like what are the challenges what
are the bugs what are the features not
tackling it that way nice yeah I think
so I I think I I did I built my first
website in like 2006 and I remember
um kind of
it was it was it was in it was in like
the computer room at school some kid had
like right clicked on the Google home
page and clicked view source and like
Internet Explorer floor or whatever it
was at the time I was like whoa this
guy's a hacker because you can see all
this the code and things and I was like
all right cool copy paste dot HTML be
like why isn't the image showing it's
like okay cool I need to reference the
image locally and and started tinkering
with stuff and then got into the world
of like yeah trying to design websites
for small businesses to make five ten
dollars here and there trying to
undercut everyone in India who was
trying to do the same thing
um were you working for yourself working
for an agency what like what did that
look like in in the early days at first
I was working for myself and then I
started working as a perm all answer at
different actually fashion companies who
were putting more and more emphasis on
their web presence so they had like very
basic sites and then they hired people
like me to kind of
zip it up a little bit right you know I
had interactive shopping experiences or
have digital campaigns like falling snow
and yeah winter landscapes and make it a
little bit more creative and so you did
that for a few years and then decided to
do the startup alongside yeah a few
years I did that for like 10 years yeah
so at some point I got to be like a
senior art director at a major fashion
company specifically for web and like
that wasn't it right I thought I'd
wanted this thing and it didn't you know
the work was fine and I was grateful for
it but it wasn't necessarily fulfilling
so that's when I was kind of like
hmm maybe it's time for me to work for
myself because I put an incredible
amount of hours for other people's
dreams and it wasn't even people it's
just kind of like a huge corporation in
an industry that I wasn't particularly
interested in this was just a job so I'm
like okay let's have something a little
bit more personal something that might
be more meaningful to me and I'll create
my own company so me and
what became a friend of mine but at the
time was just a developer he had an idea
which was to create like
paint by numbers 2.0 are you familiar
with paint by numbers yeah so
he created an algorithm that would take
a photograph and then create a custom
paint by number map and so we did that
and we get like a custom paint set and
everything and so you could paint a
picture of your kids or your dog or
something like that that's nice yeah it
was a really cute product and we worked
on it and it was a lot of interesting
problems to solve
and we were proud of the product but
it's like
I don't know just paint by numbers that
wasn't that wasn't it for me right if
this is a cute product I'm proud of what
we did it was high quality but it just
wasn't interesting as a business it
wasn't fulfilling to me
and yeah so
I learned a lot in that time like
creating and launching my own business
yeah and I realized that it had
that it was empty there was something
missing and that's what happened later
so we sold the company because both of
us felt the same way he felt the same
way it was really interesting we had
this kind of existential crisis
simultaneously
you know we were proud of what we had
done and we were done with it
so it's like what happens next so when
when did you sell the company uh I would
say probably maybe
2008 something like that okay
yeah so you sell the company in 2008
like what happened the next I continue
to do work
um
as a permal answer I guess all over the
place working for companies that I
thought were interesting I tried to go
more for big digital agencies because
one thing I did like is having a variety
of different types of things to work on
but then I started also volunteering for
a lot of tech non not-for-profits and
that's where things started to shift
right because like I had volunteered
before
and that's fine but all of a sudden when
I realized that I could like use my tech
skills at scale that was interesting
right yeah so I spent an hour working
here I helped two people I spend an hour
working here and the tech that I'm
working on can serve 20 000 people
and that was a really interesting
concept that never occurred to me it's
like we ship this one feature that I
designed and all of a sudden there's
housing available for 10 000 people you
know or easier that kind of thing and
that was really fascinating and that
felt very different that felt very
meaningful so like this little thing
that I was working on on the side like
helping these startups some of which
made it some of which didn't was just
significantly more fulfilling than my
day job I'm like God I wish I could do
something like this full-time because
you know as a designer I don't know how
it was like for you but a big part of
this is like I want to solve people's
problems right and in web design it's
like sure like getting Insurance faster
is solving somebody's headache
I mean some of these problems weren't
necessarily interesting but ultimately
that's what you're trying to do as a
designer is help people create tools
that remove some kind of friction from
somebody's life
and eventually what was so funny is that
the tool that I was using to organize
myself and Orient myself
was the thing that would ultimately
become the tool that I could
share and would help the most amount of
people with any of the with any of the
work that I would end up doing
what did it feel like so
having having a job where you're doing
the thing that you enjoy like you're
using your skills but it feels
unfulfilling compared to doing the same
thing and it feels fulfilling just
because because of the I guess the
industry that you're working in if
you're helping people get housing that I
imagine feels much more rewarding than
helping someone spend more money on a
fashion website for example yeah buyers
some other set of pants yeah so what
does that feel like like what and I I
guess I'm asking because I've been in
the fortunate positions so as to not
really have had a job that felt
unfulfilling in some way because I went
like straight from Medical School into
medicine into this YouTube stuff all of
which I feel I just ticked the
fulfilling box along the way and very in
varying degrees yeah so yeah what's
what's that like where you're like doing
the thing you love like you're not doing
it for the reason they care about
I think it's
I think people just have this
realization at some point that their
career is not really fulfilling you know
you have these all these goals and
sometimes you accomplish those goals so
quickly that that momentum can
remove a little bit of the existential
Terror of like looking at what you're
doing really deeply and it's like is
this meaningful is this what I want to
do it's like okay well I got the raise
cool like I'll you know buy a house and
then you focus on the house and then you
can fix up the house and like meanwhile
like your life keeps going and it keeps
going so there's ways to distract
yourself from it but I mean you hear
this thing called a midlife crisis and I
feel like that's the moment that most
people ask that question you know for me
I think I don't know if I had my midlife
crisis early but I feel like at some
point the distractions go away and then
there's this kind of subtle Reckoning
where you're like
this doesn't mean anything to me right
and having that moment
I think this is part of the human
experience and there's nothing
particularly wrong with that it's what
happens next that I find really
interesting right and how do you avoid
having that moment it's just like I
think if you don't ask yourself these
questions regularly
eventually they will appear right but if
you do you can kind of
figure this process out like what is
Meaningful to you what what is your what
are your values you ask in small little
steps and you start becoming familiar
and you approach your life with
curiosity instead of this moment where
you're like oh my God everything's
meaningless and I don't know what I'm
doing and this is like massive
self-judgment
and yeah I I found it so much more
helpful to kind of tack as I said kind
of treat my life as a product or as this
big experiment and start asking myself
like what am I curious about is this
meaningful and how do I have more of
this how do I have less of this and
approach it from a very systematic
perspective right like the whole thing
with the bullet Journal method is
I would say the thing that's lost is
what happens off the page which is most
of it it's the way that you think about
your life that changes and that's really
the exciting part for me but yeah that's
hard to share with people it is yeah so
what sort of tools were you using to
stay productive before it coalesced into
the method everything I was like a
hopeless early adopter it's like a new
app I would be on it immediately and
sometimes it helped me hear or sometimes
it helped me there but it's it's it's I
don't know
um I mean you name it I probably use the
app I use the system I used all of it
and what's funny is that I learned so
much more after I started sharing like
Bujo work right people are like oh have
you heard of David Allen I'm like no I
hadn't I probably should have at some
point but like all these great thinkers
in the space and I'm like okay what do
they say about this stuff and it's been
really exciting for me because I'm as
much of a student of all this stuff as I
am a teacher and
so yeah I continue to use stuff all the
time you know like I love this stuff
it's fun it's like okay how do I make
more how do I make better use of my time
and so what were the dots that connected
for you to result in that oh this is
this is the pen and paper based method
that I have found the most most helpful
like having having tried these like
thousand different things
um okay so there are a couple things
there one is it's not done which is the
fun part right like here are the here's
the minimum viable product that's kind
of what I share with people like you're
the fewest amount of tools I've found to
be successful over the longest period of
time try them on for size and see if
they work for you
um I think that I never intended on
sharing this so maybe we can approach it
from that angle what happened was that
people always saw me sitting down with a
notebook especially in the as somebody
that's a digital native and working in
digital design people like you always
have a notebook what are you doing in
there I'm like well
thinking that's what I'm doing I'm
trying to figure out stuff drawing
whatever it's a canvas and then people
would be like well so how would you deal
with this problem or how would you deal
with this problem or how would you
organize this and I would show them like
one piece of the methodology more at
that time just what I was doing and I
found over and over again that no matter
what their background was it would be
useful
especially for people who only did
things online
and I was like huh maybe I should share
some of this stuff
um
and that's kind of what ended up
incentivizing me to coalesce everything
to share it and so I stripped everything
out but the most helpful tools that the
things that had worked over the longest
period of time and a lot of that's just
about writing down your thoughts that's
the core of it like in bullet Journal
you write down three things the things
you have to do the things that you
experience and the things you don't want
to forget and then you come back to
those things in regular intervals that's
the greatly
diminished version of bullet journaling
it's writing things down and reading
what you wrote and trying to connect the
dots over time
so those three three those three things
were writing down what you have to do
tasks events and notes tasks events and
notes
okay yeah I guess that's kind of what
mine looks like as well but because so I
guess you must get this a lot but I like
I I first I mean I'd heard of the the
method like years ago on some random
productivity blog or something I always
thought oh interesting like um I'll file
that in for later to try at some point
and then uh my friend Matt diabella did
a video recently where he tried bullet
journaling and I was like oh okay
interesting like it's not too artsy foxy
like I I sort of imagined it would be
sure and then I started watching a few
other videos about it I was like oh this
actually is really helpful like I I need
a way to look at my year for the whole
year because I think like the problem
with Google Calendar is that like it's
forces you to think very zoomed in and
if you try and zoom out like suddenly
you can't see anything at all because
now it's just little dots on a thing and
I was like oh this is this like future
log thing it seems great oh like month
of the glance yeah that'll be really
helpful just being able to see my
calendar at glance and figure out like
you know where where do I have blocks in
my calendar where I should probably take
some time off and go on holiday or
something and
oh you know this daily thing of like
actually figuring out what your most
important task is for the day or what
tasks you have to do I was sort of doing
a version of that and so we we released
our own like stationary line which where
it's like every day is a page and it
asks you three things you're grateful
for I'll see what's your most important
task and sort of the my to-do list
things that you might you might want to
do with like a little brain dump area
um I was like I'm also I'm already kind
of using this this sort of most
important task method let's try this
bullet Journal thing and then I came
across the book
and I listened to the book on Audible
and I think that might have been a
mistake because it was it was like hard
to imagine what was going on when just
listening to it on Audible and so I
think that that's one of the tricky
things about this because I guess it's
it is somewhat visual but I guess like
with with that caveat in mind so like
what are the like the core principles I
guess of of the method
um and obviously people oh we'll put
links to the the book which I recommend
not getting on Audible because then you
can you can see what's going on when you
get it on Kindle or in real life it
really helps to see what's being talked
about for sure
um
okay
tasks events notes tasks tasks events
and notes so I'm trying to think of a
way to have a non-visual yeah version of
describing this I think the best way to
think about it is writing down your
thoughts in a really distilled way so a
lot of people
know how powerful journaling can be
right they hear about all the mental
health benefits that it can have and I
very much encourage long-form journaling
but it takes a lot of time right and a
lot of people see it only as an
emotional thing right it's like I
Journal when I'm confused or when I'm
sad or when I'm angry and that can be
helpful and then you have bulleted
bullet lists which essentially are for
very specific things this is what I have
to buy you know these are my goals these
are all these things so bullet
journaling kind of combines The Best of
Both Worlds where it helps you organize
your thoughts as bulleted lists that's
one component there's two parts of the
bullet Journal method the system and the
practice the prac the system is how you
organize information and then the
practice is more about what you do with
what you write down I like to say that
you know writing down writing things
down is only the beginning
so you write down the things that you
experience so your events the things
that you don't want to forget which are
your notes and then uh your tasks things
that are actionable right okay sorry
please go ahead and each one of those
has a different icon in front of it so
as you're writing things down you're
also categorizing your thoughts in real
time
and the only way to make that
sustainable is figure out a way to write
down less right you're really trying to
focus on what really matters and that is
part of the practice right you're
listening to somebody and you're like it
focuses it helps you become an active
listener right it's like what about this
is the takeaway specifically so you're
starting to
think about what's being said in a very
different way because like hearing and
listening are two very different things
so it's okay what about this is
important and then using your own words
to capture it and that process as well
like using your own words helps you
retain it better and helps you make it
more personal all these things and
you're doing this throughout the day so
information that's coming from the
outside being filtered through your
brain and then being added to your
bullet Journal so that's like a big part
of it capturing things
and you record so the Bullet Journal
method Works in a cycle which is record
reflect refine and respond and those are
like the four steps so you record by
writing things down
then you reflect on the things that you
wrote down and try to come up with
insights and different takeaways and
then you take action accordingly right
that's essentially what you're trying to
do the bullet Journal creates both
a framework for you to organize your
information but also how to think about
your information and then make all that
Insight actionable that's the big part
like what do you do with what you learn
all right we're just going to take a
quick break from the podcast to
introduce our sponsor which is very
excitingly heal I have been a paying
customer of huel since 2017 so it's been
about six years now that I've been using
Hume fairly regularly I started eating
Hill in my fifth year of medical school
and I've been using heal regularly ever
since because you know I like to be
productive I you know my calendar is
full with a lot of things and often I
don't have the time or don't make the
time to have a particularly healthy
breakfast or a particularly healthy
lunch my favorite flavor is salted
caramel because 400 calories you get 40
grams of protein which is absolutely
insane and you also get a decent healthy
mix of carbohydrates and fiber and fat
along with 26 different vitamins and
minerals which are all very good for the
body there's nine different flavors of
this to choose from my favorite is a the
banana version and also the Salted
Caramel version so what I do is I take
my two scoops I put them into my
NutriBullet blender type thing although
you can just use a normal Shaker if you
want I mix it up normally with water but
a little bit of milk to add a bit more
of a milkshake-like consistency to it
and then I just sip that while I'm on my
desk doing my work in the morning and it
ensures that I get a very healthy
breakfast in that's nutritionally
complete rather than some high sugar
cereal which is what I would have
defaulted to instead also heal is
ridiculously reasonably priced like a
meal 400 calories comes out to one pound
68 per meal which is super super cheap
compared to what the alternative would
be if you were ordering takeout for
example anyway if you like the idea of
getting these cheap and healthy and
nutritionally complete meals in your
diet then head over to heal.com forward
slash Deep dive and if you use that URL
heal.com forward slash Deep dive they
will send you a free t-shirt which are
quite nice and also a free kind of
shaker bottle type thing with your first
order so thank you so much Hill for
sponsoring this episode this episode is
very kindly brought to you by
trading212. now people ask me all the
time for advice about investing because
I've made a bunch of videos about it on
the YouTube channel and my advice for
most people is generally invest in Broad
stock market index funds which is
exactly what you can do completely for
free with trading 212. it's a great app
that lets you trade stocks and funds and
ETFs and foreign exchange if you really
want to and one of the great things
about the app is that if you're new to
the world of investing you can actually
invest with fake money you don't have to
put real money in they've got a practice
mode where you invest fake money and
then it actually tracks what the market
is doing in real time so you can see had
I invested 100 pounds into this thing
what would my return have been X weeks
or X months further down the line once
you've got some comfort with that then
it's super easy to deposit money into
your trading tool into account you can
use Apple pay like I do initially or you
can use a direct bank transfer and then
once the money is in your trading 212
account then you can invest it in
basically whatever you want now if
you're based in the UK you might be
familiar with the concept of an Isa
which is an individual savings account
which is basically a tax-free wrapper
that you can put money in you can put 20
000 pounds in every year up to twenty
thousand pounds and it resets every
April and then all that money can grow
and it's completely tax-free for the
rest of your life and if you want to
sign up for an iso you can sign up for
one completely for free also on trading
212. so if you haven't yet filled up
your eyes allowance or at least put some
money into your ISO for this year that
might be a good step forward the app
also lets you Auto invest which is a
great thing because then you can
automatically invest a percentage of
your paycheck into the thing every month
and so if you haven't yet started with
investing and you want to give it a go
then you can download the app on the App
Store and if you use the coupon code Ali
Ali at the checkout that will give you a
totally free share worth up to a hundred
pounds it's available on iPhone Android
and you can check it out by typing in
trading 212 into your respective App
Store so thank you so much trading212
for sponsoring this episode so I
yeah so having having lessons to the
book on Audible and sort of watching a
few YouTube videos about this
one thing that I sort of took away and I
I think I got this i got this from the
book because initially I watched a few
of these like fancy artsy people with
cool really cool spreads and stuff
and then I listened to the book I was
like oh okay this is actually simpler
than I was kind of imagining it to be
and one of the things I really liked
about it is that it's it's very like
modular like you can just
slot in the modules or the the pages
that work for you and just get rid of
the ones that don't yeah
um and so mine has I mean over the last
like 30 days or so of doing this it's
really well it's it's evolved a fair bit
and I imagine it will continue to evolve
in terms of what I personally find
useful but I found that like and I don't
know if this is the actual notation but
I found that I use one symbol for like
events
um I use a symbol for tasks and I use
them for notes you know and I I also do
like morning pages in it so like you
know writing a few pages of by hand of
you know just basic journaling how I'm
feeling what I'm thinking about some
stuff relates to the book and sort of
brainstorming titles and things and I
have this um at the start of the month
a double page spread that has sort of
things I'm grateful for and homework for
life are you familiar with homework for
life so there's a book called story
worthy by Matthew Dixon best one of the
best books I've ever read um I talked
about like how to become a better
Storyteller and the idea is that every
single day at the end of the day you
write down the most story worthy moment
that happened that day something that
made this day different from any other
and you just write it down in a few
words and he does it unlike a Google
sheet or something just so he's got the
things and I've been doing this on and
off for a few years but I realized that
hey if I'm if I'm using the bullet
journal every day which I which I now am
then tagging tagging on this sort of
just nightly journaling thing just like
what was one thing that made today
different and so I've been doing that
since September the 1st up until
September the 21st so I'm like a day out
of date here
um and it's been so nice to have a
physical thing to kind of ground myself
weirdly like in the morning
I get out the notebook and I'm like
what's my most important task for today
cool can I feel you know can I be
bothered to do the morning Pages yeah
depending on how I'm feeling sometimes I
type it out sometimes I write it by hand
and then in the evening you know what
are some things I'm grateful for and
what is my story worthy moment and it's
sort of like bookends the day nicely in
terms of the morning and the evening
practice
um yeah like
and so so the the method is mindfulness
disguises a productivity system yeah
like
from what we've talked about so far task
events notes that doesn't feel like it
would help you answer the question of
like why am I why am I here on this
Earth yeah so I think the best way to
think about the bullet Journal method as
a whole is as your laboratory for life
right and
I like using a notebook because it's a
blank page essentially and you create
whatever game or goal you want to play
every day
and what's beautiful about this
methodology it's powered by your
intention what is it that you're curious
about what do you want more of what do
you want less of and then you start
finding the tools that's help support
that I provide a bunch of different
tools to help you organize your thoughts
and different rituals so daily ritual
weekly ritual monthly ritual those kind
of things to help you check in but a big
part of this is about self-discovery
right so
for me the thing that was so challenging
growing up is people kept shoving
productivity systems down my throat like
this will make you smart this will make
you more productive but none of them
work the way that my mind worked and a
big part about bullet journaling is
discovering what works for you and that
changes all the time which is what makes
it relevant over time right like when
you're working nine to five it's one
thing when you become a parent it's
another thing when you start traveling
it's another thing when you're reading
this it becomes a different thing you
know and that's what keeps on making it
relevant so I provide a basic Foundation
that helps
keep everything on the rails if you will
but then it's like your your laboratory
and you get to experiment with that all
of it revolves around thinking like
that's a big part of it how do you
organize your thinking around your
intention around your values around your
curiosity so we have tasks events and
notes that's the most basic
piece of the puzzle right these are the
things that are happening and a lot of
times people think notes are just
you know this is what I have to do
tomorrow or you know somebody likes the
color blue but for me notes are like
what are you feeling what's coming up
right so like okay I did this thing and
I feel this way and then we have rituals
to come back to
all of this content and be like oh
that's interesting I worked on this
thing and I've been feeling sad all
month
like this project that I thought was
really exciting is actually just really
bumming me out and it's not bringing me
closer to what I want and I wouldn't
have noticed that unless I had read my
own story
and that's what you're doing with bullet
journaling you're writing your own story
and you're starting to realize when that
story is not making sense or it's not
the story you want to tell and then
every morning you wake up and you start
telling that story anew
I found that I started I started writing
those sorts of things recently oh like
Wednesday the 21st so like two days ago
I wrote
um event podcast with Alex and Mateo
event podcast with Tim
um this other thing that was canceled
this I think it was canceled and I said
that oh I did it uh intermittent fasting
12 to 8 feeding window felt great
and I have never written down something
like that before Amy except like the day
before I was like oh you know let me
actually write down how I'm feeling with
this bullet journaling type stuff
and just the fact that I now have those
two data points that hey I actually only
ate in between 12 and 8 pm felt pretty
good that's really useful for me for me
to know because I probably would have
thought that or felt that in the past
but the fact that I hadn't written it
down means that it didn't register with
me in some way
and now I'm like oh this intermittent
fasting stuff really has something going
for it and today I had breakfast with my
brother so I didn't do that so I'm
curious as to how my kind of how my body
feels and stuff when I don't do that
um
okay so so we've got task event notes
which feels like kind of ground level
like
here in the moment on the like almost on
a daily Cadence what are the tasks event
notes what other what other I guess
modules or tools are there that help
guide more like intentionality yeah so
essentially I would say that the
practice is more about intentionality so
every bullet Journal I always encourage
people to set an intention what is it
that you want to learn about yourself
right or what challenge do you want to
tackle what goal or ambition do you have
and then a lot of your notes will be
anchored around that
and so that's really helpful it
and in order for that to work you need
rituals right I I prefer the word
rituals over habits because I feel like
habits
like brushing my teeth have you also
send it said for me habits are things
there are behaviors that you're trying
to make automatic right that's it like
the ideal thing is that you go to the
gym and you don't even realize that that
happened I don't know in my own life
I've I don't think I've ever created a
good habit that I haven't had to think
about a lot
which is why I think rituals are so much
more important because a ritual is a set
of behaviors that serves something
meaningful and actually doing those
things requires a lot of attention right
so in bullet Journal we don't have
habits we have rituals and we have daily
rituals weekly rituals monthly rituals
yearly rituals and they help us think at
different time scales about our life
right it's what's what's happening today
might not have context yet what's
happening next week doesn't have context
yet but it will help you contextualize
the days and monthly and so forth so it
helps us increase the resolution of both
our past and what we want in our future
we start identifying our own patterns by
simply reading the story that we're
writing down about our life and when we
realize it's like oh I really wish I
knew about this then all of a sudden you
can just start taking notes from today
onward about that how are you feeling
about your relationship how are you
feeling about your job how is this
project making you feel so you become
the author based on your intention on
your focus and that shifts constantly
and that's why every bullet Journal is
completely unique to its author what's a
what are some rituals that you
personally find helpful I guess daily
weekly monthly annual yeah
um writing is really important for me
it's so I have regular intervals of
longer form journaling so for me longer
form journaling is actually quite taxing
but it's also immensely helpful so in my
weekly ritual I will have a longer
journaling session about the week gone
by for my month it'll be about the last
four weeks that kind of thing of the
year or
when I get to the end of my notebook
it's about the notebook like what have I
learned
and that's really helpful so I've been
doing a lot of that
that's a great ritual also just taking
the time to read what I wrote like
that's a very consistent ritual for mine
of mine just sitting down at the end of
the day and like what do I need to do
what do I not need to do so that's
another really important part about
bullet journaling we rewrite a lot of
our content
that's a big part where we call it
migration so every day every week every
month we you know pick our priorities
and we also move things forward and in
that process we make a choice about
the things that we are going to keep in
our lives and the things that we let go
of so having rituals where we say no
regularly
is a core part of bull adrenaline it's
not about keeping never-ending to-do
lists it's about having a systematized
way of curating your life on an ongoing
basis based on how your priorities
change your circumstances change so the
rituals are there to recommit to things
and let things go and reorganize right
so like not only are you moving your
content you're also
incrementally changing the way that you
organize your content it's like not only
what you're organizing but how you're
organizing it it's like oh this
collection
is not really working like this health
tracker isn't really doing anything for
me why not I don't know and a lot again
this gives us an opportunity to approach
something with curiosity do is this
Fitness routine not working for me or is
it the way I'm organizing the fitness
routine
and it gives you an opportunity to ask
that question and think about it and
then take that insight and then
improve it next month next week so it's
an iterative approach to
curating your life
I think that's something that I'm not
doing consciously enough or like as
consciously as I would want to just like
really thinking
of the intention behind the thing
because
I think
like one thing one thing I have noticed
these days is you know I have I have my
personal trainer sessions a few times a
week
um but I never look forward to it I'm
always glad that it's over and I feel
like sometimes the thought strikes me
that hmm this thing feels a bit grim and
like when he cancels on me I'm just like
yes thank God for that uh
and if I were more intentional about how
I was feeling and like writing writing
that down like if at the start of the
month I'd be like oh whenever huh I
wonder how I feel about my gym sessions
and then I would write down how I feel
after each one and then I'd think okay
you know what are some other ways to get
exercise I enjoy playing squash how do I
feel after a squash session feel
freaking great that's a sign to me that
actually
do I really want to do this gym thing
just for the sake of getting slightly
bigger biceps probably not like why
don't I do something I actually enjoy is
it is is that sort of along the lines of
what you mean by kind of being
intentional about Bingo you know I think
that a lot of us
myself included fall into this
trap of like automating a lot of our
lives or trying to and then it's no
surprise that a lot of the things you've
automated feel meaningless or even worse
they feel
like a real drain on your energy you
know it's it's really hard to go to the
gym for yourself but when you realize
that you're doing this thing because
your health is at stake or like whatever
you're doing this exercise because you
want to be around for your kids like
even a thing that's
feels meaningless to you all of a sudden
gets a real sense of purpose so taking a
moment to think about why you're doing
what you're doing regularly can help you
reconnect to your purpose your why your
value so even the things that aren't fun
like nobody likes doing the dishes right
very few people but it's a way for you
to show your partner that you're
committed to this relationship so if you
only focus on you not doing the dishes
no big deal but if you focus on you
wanting to like have a sustainable and
healthy relationship you're like okay I
know why I'm doing this it does make the
dishes great but it doesn't feel like a
waste of time and that's when things I
think get really dangerous when you feel
like things are a waste of time or
they're meaningless and some things are
and it's really important to stay aware
of that sometimes we're just doing
things because they snuck into our to-do
list and then even things that we were
excited about and become like oh I have
to learn French now because
two years ago I thought that was cool
and now I feel ashamed that I have done
these classes even though I'm not at all
interested in learning French now
so you're just curating and letting go
of things constantly based on your
current circumstances
so do you have I guess the the term you
use is collections yeah for like the
modules of the bullet Journal kind of
thing so basically collections you can
think of them as a combination of
folders and apps but it's where you put
all related content so if it's about a
project chances our projects usually
start as one idea then two ideas and
three ideas over time and then during
one of the rituals you start realizing
like oh actually this is going to be a
great article so I'm going to take all
this stuff and put it into a collection
or I I'm going to start a project and I
want to dump all my ideas in there
immediately you create a collection or I
want to create a fitness tracker you
create a collection so that's where you
store related ideas and then you have
this thing called the index which kind
of speaks for itself where you write
down the name of that collection so you
can quickly find it again later
and then you can quickly find all the
projects and focuses in your life
where
so this this idea of of like in
intentionality
where does that come into the system I
guess if if at all which is because I I
guess
yeah like uh I I think Hmm
this is a bit of a rambling thought but
I find that sometimes
the system leads to the behavior that I
want to
develop for example the fact that I I
have a page called gratitude that I fill
in every day and the fact that I see a
gap from yesterday means like oh yeah
[__] I should I should do this and and
fill that in
whereas normally I might forget to keep
track of you know things the things I'm
grateful for or this homework for Life
thing where I I write down something
story worthy that happened
the fact that I have the page as part of
the system means I will I'm doing the
thing so I guess kind of for me what is
something I can do in my bullet Journal
that would help me I don't know just be
a bit more intentional I guess with with
him spending my time well I mean it
sounds to me like you are being quite
intentional already
but a lot of it is just asking yourself
questions is this serving me is this not
serving me the idea of the ritual is
that you take the step back and just
look at the things that you're working
on is it serving you are you getting
anything out of it why why not and then
based on that reflection if you will you
make a choice do I continue doing this
or do I not and then you understand why
it's about being intentional about your
actions and your decisions on a ongoing
basis because life changes and your
focus and your priorities change so it's
about recommitting over and over again
letting things go that's what's
intention that's what's intentional for
me it's about aligning your actions with
your values with your beliefs
right over and over again because it
changes
so for example a gratitude log is
wonderful it's it's but it must serve a
purpose right A lot of people do these
things because they're told too you know
it's in the productivity space like you
can spend all day doing your morning
ritual you know meditate three hours do
the ice bath do you know journaling
everything and if you don't know we've
had no connection to it it won't feel
meaningful so
for me productivity is very much about
experimentation to see what resonates
with you and learning about yourself it
can serve as a mirror and I find that
the notebook is a great it's a paper
mirror right it's reflecting your
choices back at you which one of those
are helping you lead the life that you
want and which ones are not and what are
you going to do about that
and then you make a choice
do you migrate it do you not migrate it
what do you leave behind what do you say
yes to what do you say no to and you're
doing that every day so the choice
doesn't become this major existential
rabbit hole it's like oh my god do I
start this company or not you know yeah
can you describe this process of
migration I guess for people that might
not be familiar with it yeah so the
biggest migration happens once a month
and essentially what you do is you go
back through the previous month and you
look at all the tasks that are still
open I've been doing this for a really
long time and I've never gotten
everything every single thing done so
there's two options there a lot of us
are like oh wow I'm lazy I didn't do
this stuff and then you beat yourself up
and that's the end of it or
what I try to advocate for is ask
yourself why did this not get done right
from a genuine part of curiosity and
then a journey in place of curiosity
and then you start figuring out
the reason it was too big it was too
complicated I don't care about this
thing and we use this thing called the
filter where we ask ourselves three
questions
is this thing vital right does this need
to get done and vital things are usually
things that would get us in trouble
right rent student loans whatever then
the second question is does it matter
does it matter to you or to someone that
you love usually it's easier to answer
whether or not something matters to
Somebody That You Love
but when it comes to us it can be a
little bit of a grayer area right does
this still matter to me and it's a very
basic question but oftentimes you see
that like the French lessons are a great
great example it's like okay I've been
migrating this thing month after month
after month after month and I have to be
honest with myself I don't care about
learning French anymore and I can just
let that go
right so does it matter yes or no and
you get to determine that so you're
being intentional about what you're
recommitting to and then the third
question if you don't know if it's vital
or if it matters are there any
consequences for not doing it ever it
just changes the context around and if
you can't think of a single reason or a
single consequence
for not doing this thing the chances are
it's not vital and it doesn't matter and
then you actually just cross it off you
leave it behind so once a month you're
making a choice of what you want to
recommit to and then
you rewrite those things in your next
monthly log
so that way you're constantly curating
the things that you're allowing into
your life like in the bullet Journal
your tasks aren't just stuff you have to
do these are all experiences waiting to
be born because every action requires
time and attention this is how your life
is constructed this is how your life is
built so you're choosing what you want
your life to consist out of every month
and if something isn't even worth a
moment to rewrite it because people are
always like oh wait I have to rewrite
stuff that's going to take way too much
time it's a waste of time I'm like if
something's not worth a moment to
rewrite it then chances are it's not
adding a lot of value to your life so
it's not really
a bug it's a feature yeah this was a big
a big kind of firmware upgrade I had in
my mind for this thing that like exactly
this is this thing that you just said
that it's not a bug it's a feature I
think I think before I was I I had some
friends who did build a journaling I was
like wait what every month you like draw
out the calendar for the month what a
waste of time and you write down things
that you like migrate them from the pre
like screw that like and then I tried it
I was like oh I get it like the fact
that I am writing down an event multiple
times once in my annual log once in my
monthly log means that AI look forward
to it more and B the ones I don't look
forward to I'm like wait a minute why am
I doing this thing yeah and so I say no
to more things I just looked at sort of
the the monthly thing that I did I I
migrated from the previous month sign up
to new gym because I'm moving house so I
need to do that cancel subscription with
current gym which I actually completely
forgot about until I just read it now so
I would have in a week from now I would
have seen that and been like oh crap I
actually need to do that get premium
couples therapy with my girlfriend just
because why not I think that's an
important for growing a system for
having lunch with a team I think that's
important
um
there was this thing I was thinking
around like do I want to take a
psychedelic and it's like I I don't
actually don't think that's important to
me right now so I could just cross that
because I don't want to migrate it over
and sign up for kickboxing I still think
that would be a cool thing to do I
haven't signed up yet so I'll just
migrate it over to the next month which
will be I guess October
and
now I at least have those written down
so whether it gets done or not is
relevant at least I have it written down
and I've actively every month decided
that the things that I'm migrating to
this month are sufficiently important at
this point in time
and then I'll do them at some point or
not but either way the fact that I've
written them down means that they are
there
absolutely and you get a moment to kind
of check in with yourself and feel into
it you know does this feel meaningful
does is this something you're excited
about or not and I that might seems like
such a basic question about how often do
we ask ourselves that of our to-do list
does this seem exciting is this a game
that I want to play you know is this an
experiment that I want to run because
it's all experiments all of these things
if you're not interested in the
experiment then you better have a really
good reason for investing your very
limited time and attention into you know
and that's what's so fun about it I get
to decide
what am I going to commit to what am I
not going to commit to and why because
then you get to learn about things like
these are things that do not
seem important to me because I identify
this pattern over years right it's it's
the paper mirror I'm not doing well
right now I what can I do about that
what what can I ask for help okay like
can I get something off my plate so it
helps you really check in with yourself
and connect with yourself
which is something that I find
so important and valuable that it's hard
to exaggerate and all you're doing is
writing things down on paper I mean sure
you can do it in apps like you don't
need to do it a notebook what I love
about a notebook it helps you go offline
immediately you know for me when I was
bullet journaling digitally which I've
tried of course it's like I'm writing
something down that's really meaningful
to me and all of a sudden I'm buying
socks I'm like wait a second how did
that happen yeah you know what I mean
with a notebook
you just think differently yeah
yeah okay because of some some very
tactical questions here let's say
you know David Allen talks about capture
as to tell guys does everyone in the
space let's say you're I don't know
in the middle of this podcast you you
have a thought of like oh I need
speaking speaking of socks I should buy
some socks for my wife or whatever what
do you do with that
piece of information in like let's say
when when you're in the middle of
something sure I mean in the podcast I
wouldn't do it because this is the most
important part and I I would think that
it's rude but uh let's say it wasn't a
podcast and I remember something that I
have to write down goes in my daily log
so we have so you take the journal out I
physically take it out of your bag and
then you write it in your daily log yes
as like a task so the daily log is kind
of like your inbox it's a real it's the
messiest part of Ebola Journal
essentially of the daily log weekly log
monthly log to help you with your daily
weekly and monthly rituals so they're
different templates that help you
organize content based on different time
scales and the daily log is designed to
be
a good reflection of how crazy our days
can be right so it's like yeah socks you
know make sure you schedule doctor's
appointments send this person flowers I
don't feel great today or I feel great
today you know just whatever comes up
you're offloading it from your mind so
you can stay as present as possible
which is a big part of this you're just
not distracted because once you write
something down you just feel you feel
that like I don't have to worry about
the system it'll come up at some point
yes and then okay and how often are you
looking at your data log
that I mean it really depends on the day
yeah so my daily rituals in the morning
in the evening I spend between five
minutes and half an hour with it
depending on what I need like in the
morning it's usually five minutes okay
here's the priority like if I get this
one thing done
today is a victory and it really depends
on how much work I have what point what
I'm focusing on what my intention is
it's all over the place it's really hard
to say how long it takes but at least
five minutes in the morning and at least
five minutes a night so what what is the
priority today and then looking
backwards like what was the most
important thing today and is there
anything else and then throughout the
day I just write things down so I don't
have to think about it it's like oh
that's interesting you know oh that's a
good idea but this is a bad idea you
know just your thinking just gets
captured and I don't really worry about
and that's what the bullet like in the
bullet Journal it's like I can quickly
categorize my thoughts as well it's like
oh this is just an idea and if it's a
really
important or exciting idea then I
actually have a different symbol for
that right I turn the dash which is the
note symbol into a plus which means
expand
and that kind of thing so later on I can
sit down and when I have some time like
oh here's three different expands and
I'm just going to write about that or
that's going to turn into article no
that's a good idea I'm going to start
taking that that's good because I often
have like ideas for videos
where I've sort of been thinking like
hmm what do I do with a video idea
because it feels like that's the sort of
thing that it makes sense to write about
on the computer because it goes into the
motion and all that crap but
yeah I can Mark things as video ideas
yeah I mean that's one thing that's so
cool about this you make it yours right
you do what works for you I mean
learning what works for you is earned
you don't know from the beginning you
run these experiments like this is
working this is not working but yeah I
use the Plus for video ideas too usually
for article video ideas and for uh
journaling prompts like sometimes I'll
I'll get stuck on an idea or an event
that's either upsetting or confusing or
something like that and I can't sit down
the middle of the day I'm like okay I'm
gonna have like this existential
journaling session I've I've got stuff
to do so I just write down the one
bullet with a plus and it's incredibly
helpful it says like okay I don't have
to focus on that right now and when I do
have time it's like now my book is full
of prompts that I can actually unpack
this oh this is great because I I have
like a nightly journalingy type thing
where I mostly do it on a computer
because I can just type way faster and I
feel like it's been copy paste it will
into a video Etc sure but what I haven't
done is actually just have the bullet
Journal open in front of me with like
the keyboard so that I can be like oh
yeah let me expand on this idea and then
I'll expand on the idea normally I have
bullet journal in the bag and then I
kind of see those two things as being
separate but I can absolutely bring them
together and connect connect them up
that feels feels very exciting I mean
for me like you're very deeply in the
PKM space for me the bullet Journal also
solves a huge problem the PKM space it's
just like what goes into your PKM right
so it's kind of like oh here's the plus
that goes into in my case Rome so like
I'm a huge Rome guy but that's how that
works it's like okay log that that's
going to become an article
that kind of thing and I can find it
really quickly because as your bullet as
you're actually bullet journaling or
rapid logging as I call it you can just
read the margins of your pages and be
like oh here's an idea here's an idea
here's an idea here's an idea
it's part of the design geekery of the
layouts no it's great so okay so how
what what do you what do you feel like
people must get wrong about bullet
journaling I think the most common
question or the com let's say the most
common concern that I get is like I'm
not an artist I can't bullet Journal
and that's always
disheartening because if you see the
core of bullet Journal you don't need to
be able to draw a straight line in order
to Bullet Journal it's very much about
just writing down your thoughts you can
make it elaborate and you can make it
beautiful but mostly people think they
have to be an artist and it's really not
about that it's as simple as this
writing down your thoughts in a line or
two literally that's it
so
for me it's about setting an attention
what is it that you're trying to
accomplish how can this tool serve you
and then letting it unfold that way
seeing it as an experiment and seeing
what works and what doesn't and the
thing that's so beautiful about what is
it a laboratory for right I mentioned it
is a laboratory it's for you learning
about yourself seeing what tools you can
build to solve problems for the way that
you think
and the only way you're going to figure
that out is by doing it and learning
from it and like okay this layout is
really effective this one is not next
month I'm going to iterate I'm going to
iterate I'm going to iterate on the way
I organize what I'm focusing on and you
just like learn about yourself very
quickly and it's it can be really fun
yeah one of the things I really love
about this is that you actually like
even even though you sort of you have a
business around this and you've got the
fancy notebooks like you're really
trying to sell anything like anyone can
pick up any old notebook or even just
like a random piece of paper and staple
it together with another one and do the
method like it's not that hard and
there's load the blog posts and stuff on
on the website and on every everyone
else's productivity website around like
how they do it so within like 10 minutes
of watching a YouTube video or doing a
bit of research and using just a random
notebook that you have in your house you
can create your own bullet Journal
absolutely oh it was like almost like
exactly a month ago when I first started
doing it where I just like immediately
felt more intentional with how I'm
spending my time
but also weirdly I feel like
time has slowed down for me because
every day I take a moment in the morning
to figure out what I want to do for the
day and in the evening I write down what
made today different
and if I think of the rest of almost the
rest of this year pre-august
it sort of felt like it went by in a bit
of a war and I almost can't remember it
but these last 30 days
like I'm kind of surprised the month
hasn't ended because I'm like oh yeah
it's been you know I've done quite quite
a few things I've done my homework for
Life thing the story stuff and it's like
I I almost feel surprised when I get to
a new week now because I'm like oh I
have to draw out the week thing I'm like
oh yeah it's been a while it feels like
it's been a while since I've done that
and did you just very weird feeling of
like time slowing down um have you had
that like is is that something you've
heard from people yeah absolutely it's
amazing what happens when you take the
time to study your life
because otherwise I mean especially in
this digital age
time kind of vanishes and during the
pandemic my time wasn't even a thing
anymore so the way I like to talk about
this is like bullet journaling is about
taking time you know people always talk
about making time and the truth is that
time can't be made time can only be
taken it can be taken from you or it can
be taken by you
and bullet Journal is about taking the
time to figure out what kind of life you
want to live like how are you doing what
are you doing why are you doing it
regularly so it doesn't become this big
existential dilemma you know it's like
why am I doing this today oh
that's something I can delegate
so that that's time slows down when you
think about it that way and then the
time moving forward because to me it
becomes much more intentional like sure
there's times where I'm not bullet
journaling and things begin to fray a
little bit and it's like oh wow time
begins to speed up
and yeah things started falling through
the cracks so it's just like hmm it's
like taking a really deep breath and
like looking at your life and being like
okay this is where we are right now
what happens next and you get to choose
yeah
um okay let's so let's rewind back the
clock a bit let's say I think it's a 20
2013 you first started sharing stuff
about the Boudreaux
um How did the
how did your life slash business evolve
from like how how did this thing of my
my mates at work are asking me how I
manage my to-do list morph into what is
now your full-time job and a business
surrounding it where basically everyone
has heard about what bullet Journal is
yeah I mean
I had just rolled off a year uh working
on this startup for somebody else I was
just their design director and it was
kind of like a soul-crushing job we get
paid well you know all the things but I
just wanted to work on a personal
project and like okay what can I build
that's helpful right now it wasn't the
best designer in the world not the best
coder in the world but I did happen to
use my notebook in this really curious
way that seemed to be helpful I'm like
okay so why don't I sit down and
actually build a website showing people
how I use my notebook yeah
and so in 2013 I sat down for like two
three weeks and then just systematized
everything were formalized that I guess
would be the better term right okay what
is the I need some language here to
describe these processes because it's
really difficult to describe to other
people how you think it's unnatural it's
like this is how I think so I actually
had to create language and all that and
in about two weeks I came up with a
vocabulary and then designed this
website to teach people the very basics
of bulletin like it was like a four
minute video and I had to choose a name
and bulleted lists and journaling it all
kind of made sense I put it together and
launched that and
soon it got covered by this Lifehacker
website and then this thing and kind of
blew up and I didn't really know what to
do with it because I was like I'm gonna
launch it and that's it it's just there
to help people so it was just a Blog at
this point yeah where you're just like
oh here's the method here's the method
it's helped me I hope it helps you and
it was kind of like a thank you letter
to a lot of people in the early web
space just gave away their knowledge for
free like I'm trying to figure this out
this is how I solved it and I benefited
from that so much early on in my web
career like I don't know CSS or HTML I'd
like look it up online yeah
exactly I have like no idea and all
these people sharing this wealth of
information for free and I was like okay
my turn here you go and then for the
first year I didn't really know what to
do with it but it kept on gaining more
and more and more Steam and then
something happened that I didn't realize
or never occurred to me is that people
started using the bullet Journal method
to solve challenges that are
completely unknown and unfamiliar to me
you know you have people dealing with
PTSD and Veterans and stay-at-home moms
and you know like all these different
groups started coming up solving very
very different challenges with the same
tool they're just it helped them
organize their thinking in a way and it
was flexible enough to basically play
into any kind of solution that they
needed and I was like oh wow that's
really fascinating like people showing
me how to use the system for problems
that I don't have
and that got really exciting so in 2014
I was like why don't I build a website
based on how other people use bullet
Journal as opposed to me yeah and then I
created a Kickstarter
to finance a new site to like actually
hire myself because I need to eat as
well
to build a site based on other use cases
you know for for parents for teachers
for students all these things and
as a thank you I partnered with this
company called life to him to create a
notebook for higher tier backers
and
I launched the kickstarter and then with
like within a day all the notebook tiers
had sold out and people got really
grumpy about like why are the notebooks
limited like I want more notebooks so
all of a sudden this thing that was
focused on launching a new website
turned into the beginning of launching a
notebook that specifically designed for
bullet journaling you can use any
notebook you want but this thing adds a
lot of tools that are make it even
faster you know numbered pages and index
like all these different things
and that's when bullet Journal turned
into a business people really wanted the
notebook and so I started selling the
notebook and over time the notebook
became more successful and
yeah that was the beginning of the
business it's such it's such a nice
Notebook thank you like how how did you
partner with
it was an notebook that I was using at
the time so I had used other notebooks
before but I've been using notebooks all
my life and then actually I was on a
podcast and somebody's like have you
ever used lifetime notebooks this was
before bullet Journal was ever a
business it was just a Blog essentially
like no I haven't like you should try it
and I did I'm like oh wow this is
amazing and so I reached out to them and
they're like oh yeah we've actually
heard of you and I'm like would you be
willing to you know do this miniature
collaboration and all of a sudden the
demand was really high and yeah we
designed this notebook from scratch it's
it's interesting it's both a blank
canvas but also a really specific and
detailed tool that's a really
interesting
project to balance
this episode is very kindly brought to
you by wework now this is particularly
exciting for me because I have been a
painful pain customer of wework for the
last two years now I discovered it
during you know when the pandemic was in
the on the verge of being lifted and I
spent like the whole year just sort of
sitting in my room making YouTube videos
but then I discovered wework and I was a
member of me and Angus my team members
we were members of the wework in
Cambridge and they have like hundreds of
other locations worldwide as well and it
was incredible because we had this
fantastic beautifully designed office
space to go to to work and we found
ourselves like every day just at nine
o'clock in the morning just going to
wework because it was a way nicer
experience working from the co-working
space than it was just sitting at home
working these days what me and everyone
on my team has is the all access pass
which means you're not tied to a
specific wework location but it means
you can use any of their several hundred
co-working spaces around London around
the UK and also around the world and one
of the things I really love about the
co-working setup is that it's fantastic
as a bit of a change of scenery so these
days I work from home I've got the
studio at home but if I need to get some
focused writing work done and I've been
I'm feeling a bit drained just sitting
at my desk all day I'll just pop over to
the local wework which is about a 10
minute walk from where I am at take my
laptop with me I'll get some free coffee
from there I'll get a few snacks and
it's just such a great Vibe and you get
to meet cool people I made a few friends
through meeting them at wework and it's
just really nice being an environment
almost like a library but kind of nicer
because there's like a little bit of
soft music in the background and there's
other kind of startup Bros and creators
and stuff in in there as well and it's
just my absolute favorite co-working
space of all time it's super easy to
book a desk or book a conference room
using the app and it's a great place to
meet up with team members if you're
going to collaborate and you'll live in
different places they've got unlimited
tea and coffee and herbal teas and
drinks on tap and they've got soundproof
boots in which they take Zoom calls and
meetings anyway if you're looking for a
co-working space for you or your team
then I'd 100 recommend we work like I
said I've been a pain customer for
theirs for the last two years which is
why it's particularly exciting that
they're now sponsoring this episode and
if you want to get 50 off your first
booking then do head over to we.com
forward slash Ali and you can use the
coupon code Ali at checkout Ali to get
50 off your first booking so thank you
so much wework for sponsoring this
episode what went into the design of
this because like at first glance it
looks like their 1917a5 notebooks with
thicker paper but presumably like you
know you're a ux designer um and this is
the first time I've seen it IRL so
there's some some stuff that I'm missing
so yeah what was the process like of
Designing this that's also version two
so version one was so it included the
instructions about how to Bullet Journal
um I had three bookmarks which at the
time wasn't a thing numbered pages and
index so it basically created
you created all these tools to make
bullet journaling ever so slightly
easier yeah right and more formal and
then over five six years we got a lot of
feedback and then we came out with
version two so like the Artistry was
something that was never something that
I anticipated right but people like
colors and they like different pens and
everything so the next version had
thicker paper and it also has guides
inside the grid to quickly chop up your
pages to create different things and
then there's also
you know this this way of quickly seeing
what the grid of the page is so you can
create any tool you want inside and
the thinnest tool pack ever so all these
like little stickers to help you
annotate your pages or actually take the
stickers and put them in things outside
of your notebook yeah as I said like
most of the bullet Journal work happens
outside of your notebook so the
lightning bolt for example is for you to
remember an intention that you set like
maybe it's to brush your teeth more
often so you just put the lightning bolt
on your mirror you know it's something
that you oh that's kind of yeah it's
just put it wherever you want every time
you see it it triggers a uh behavior
nice what's the what are the circles for
same thing it's just like if you don't
like lightning bolts you can do that or
you can highlight things inside your
notebook that are super important so
nice
so yeah that has a detachable notebook
so you can actually learn about it while
you have the notebook open
so that's a guide this is so nice it's
so nice it's so like the type everything
about this is just so classy oh thank
you
yeah I'm a stickler for good typography
um yeah it's a it's fun because I spend
so much my time teaching that like being
able to work on physical products is
kind of like I get the design again and
I do love that where did the name bullet
Journal come from
well I was trying to figure out a way to
create a title where it took away a lot
of the guesswork yeah so it's bulleted
lists and journaling bullet journal and
quite honestly it was like a URL that
was available at the time there's all
these other ones like Omni journal and
like you know all these things but the
URL was available it was memorable and
just you know I never anticipated that
it would become what it has
so I just like got it and launched and
then all of a sudden it blew up and like
oh
I'm uh you know I could have spent a
little longer thinking about the name
but here we are wow this is so cool
genuinely so nice
um how do you feel about the fact that
bullet Journal has been uh artsified so
much by people
yeah I feel really split about that at
first I was really against it I'm like
that gets in the way it's like the whole
I was worried that people were using it
as a way to procrastinate right to like
sit down to plan and they spend like an
hour designing their calendar or like a
yearly calendar I don't do yearly
calendar that was something that just
came up in the community
it's pretty helpful I find this super
helpful yeah this is how I learned from
the community because I you know I'm in
touch with the community and be like hey
like
I noticed that you did a video where you
set up this thing and it looks like it
took you like two and a half hours to do
like when you see my monthly log it
takes me five minutes like setting up my
template usually five minutes in all of
my templates
so when I see these things on YouTube I
was at first I was like horrified I'm
like no who's gonna do that right and
this is where I realized that for a lot
of people when they do this art it's a
way for them to connect with their
creative side it's like the only place
in their life where they can do this
maybe they are you know a dentist or
that you know they they were an artist
in a past life and they get to sit down
it's like for an hour I'm going to take
this time for myself and make this thing
pretty and elaborate and it helps me
connect with my values and my goals and
relaxes me and I'm like that's the point
you're connecting with the things that
matter to you
and in that case I think it's wonderful
and it never occurred to me because
that's not how I do that right but this
is how you learn from each other
when people see that however and feel
like that's the only thing that you do
with a bullet journal or that they need
to do that to get the value out of it
that's when it gets challenging because
a lot of people will sit down they've
heard all this wonderful stuff about
bullet journaling and then they see that
it's taken somebody four hours to do
something or it takes them that long or
they try it and it looks ugly and
they're like okay this this sucks this
is this means nothing to me it doesn't
work
and that's kind of heartbreaking because
they never really figured out what it
was or never got to what's below it like
a lot of the artists that I had spoken
with developed the style an intentional
choice at a time yeah right for them the
minimal version of this was not super
helpful but being able to illustrate was
but now I have the reverse problem where
a lot of people start with the super
elaborate and like I don't get anything
done because I'm spending so much time
setting it up and it's not by choice
it's just because they don't know
so it's it's uh
I always tell people start with the
basics start with something that's
really meaningful to you what with your
intention and then develop your style
over time you know the expression is
very much yours but it has to serve a
real purpose otherwise you know it's
it's not going to work
hmm no the fun is great
and also it's a balance sure like some
people will spend all day designing and
perfectly getting their planner ready
and not get anything done you know so
you
being self-aware in that regard is also
important so I have nothing against the
art it's about
what is motivating the art yeah
yeah that makes a lot of sense yeah I
think when I first started this uh so I
I actually started on an old uh lokiton
1917. and I thought you know what let's
just like MVP this like I don't want to
do all the odd stuff and plus Sharpie
was bleeding through the paper on atgsm
anyway so I was like okay this is fine
and then after seven days I was like all
right now September has started I'm
gonna take this and and do it in an
artsy kind of way and I was thinking oh
I can make a video about this we set up
an overhead rig and everything and just
it literally took like three hours to
make it look good and I was like hmm how
do I feel about the fact that this has
taken so long and I I actually did feel
good about it um because to me I like
it's it's like that thing you said like
everything I do is so digital that to be
able to get some nice pastel colored
highlighter pens with some Emoji
stickers and stick them on the page I
didn't know what washi tape was I found
out what washi tape was after watching
uh Amanda Rachel's videos like oh this
is a thing it's like oh this is cute
like I get to explore my slightly more
creative on paper side while also just
the fact that I'm taking the time to
draw out the whole year and the whole
month is making me think yeah
I I have got lots of stuff back to back
there like do I really want to do all
these things and so it was like
mindfulness and intentionality at the
same time as expressing creativity which
felt really nice but like last week I
mean at the start of this week we've
we've got a whole week of batch filming
of the podcast and so my weekly log is
very Bare Bones I'm just like date line
line line done and I think over time
I've become kind of less precious about
what's in what's in this and a sort of
embracing some level of messiness
although it still looks somewhere
aesthetic I think
um no it's been it's been really good so
thank you for inventing no sure yeah I
love that you have that you're starting
to embrace this journey which is really
what happens you know a lot of people
will start like really creatively and
become much more minimal and then
eventually they'll start becoming much
more creative with it and more minimal
it's like different times in their life
and having a tool that's
always there no matter what stage you
are in life I found to be invaluable and
I've learned how flexible it can be from
other people and embrace that as well
because at first I was trying to be very
rigid about this methodology like it has
to be this way and I'm like no that's
not how I work that's not how I bet
anybody in the community works like how
can we Embrace flexibility and structure
at the same time and for me it boils
down to intention and intention is the
structure and then you
you use the tools that help you
experiment and figure out what that
intention means to you
now we can execute it and embody the
things that you value yeah
um so you launched the kickstarter what
happens next like how how are you
feeling when it was blowing up like what
was going through your mind
it was a very strange time in my life
because I had just started a new job
with a digital agency like the week
before I launched the kickstarter which
was very unintentional it just kind of
became that it happened that way
and so I launched the Kickstart I didn't
expect much but it became like this
whole media sensation in itself because
it was still in the early days of
Kickstarter and it blew up and then I
had to manage the kickstarter
that was a nightmare that was an
absolute nightmare October 2015. I've
just brought up the kickstarter yeah it
was uh
you should have a team to help you with
the kickstarter because having a
full-time job and running a Kickstarter
especially when you're trying to ship
things internationally like a bad idea
but uh you know after I got over that
eventually I had to figure out what was
more important to me like this
incredible career that I had been
working so hard on I loved my job I like
was doing everything I wanted to do
or focus on this kind of side gig
and eventually I
came to the conclusion that the the way
that I can serve people best is to
Shepherd this methodology that
I never dreamed would have helped other
people but it did and I got countless
letters about how it helped different
people and if I would only if I could
only be a Nexus point to introduce it to
other people and see how it helped them
then that would be
far more meaningful than anything else
that I'd worked on so
the choice became pretty easy eventually
so you quit the job yeah and went full
time on this yeah
how did you know it was going to make
enough money to go full time on this
because because for like the kickstarter
like 79 000 pledged
presumably you could have made more
working at the agency oh yeah New York I
made way more money yeah at my job
well
um I didn't
I didn't uh
for me it was a gamble it was a risk I
had a very large community at the time
and the business was doing all right but
I didn't mind living on less if I could
wake up and really care about what I did
all the time and I did
so for a little while like that was a
big thing but then came the book deal
yeah so I made the choice I was like
okay I got a transition because I'm not
doing really well in bullet Journal I'm
not doing really well my job because I
was so torn and that's exactly the
opposite of what I'm trying to get
across being intentional about the
choices you make so I was like okay I
gotta practice what I preach here it's
like am I going to do this career that's
really comfortable and exciting or am I
going to do this thing that's super
scary and I don't know what's going to
happen
and I was like well how what is
what is a core value and its service for
me service is just a core driving
principle and this is the thing that
aligns with that so it became pretty
obvious when I sat down and took the
time and then I was really lucky that a
book deal came along and that helped
that's when I started writing the book
um so you do so you so you got the
partnership with lowest term around 2014
2015-ish 2014 before the the uh
so the partnership kind of developed
throughout the kickstarter because the
first it was limited to like a thousand
notebooks like that was the partnership
it was a quick collaboration and then
both of us saw that there was a real
demand for it so that quickly
became the partnership that you see
today and working with them has been
absolutely delightful they make it
possible I couldn't possibly do this by
myself and it was just me for the
longest time and then I just kept on
focusing on creating more content and
surfacing people in my community that
was like the main thing finding people
so unlike myself that used this for in
ways that I would have never imagined
finding other people and yeah that
worked people it was it was amazing and
then
no and the thing that was interesting is
uh when I first shared bullet Journal
was very much more focused towards the
productivity thing because I wasn't
really
comfortable talking about
the more existential part of it right
it's like the why that's that's I don't
I didn't think I was qualified or you
know that people were interested
but now years had been going by and more
and more and more people were a bit like
something's happening while I'm doing
this like you know you had mentioned
that there's somewhat of a state shift
in the way that you start per se
perceiving time and your life and this
happens to people quite regularly and I
hear about it all the time and I started
answering emails like okay it's not
about like setting goals it's about
setting meaningful goals or like how do
I know what is Meaningful what is not
meaningful because people started
becoming more and more productive and
they keep running into this problem
where they
get things done and then like a day a
week a month later it's like it never
like they just normalize and then it's
over right it's like okay so you got the
six pack you know but you're still
insecure so it doesn't that that wasn't
the goal wasn't about the six-pack it
was figuring out a way to become more
confident you know and that's a very
different Journey you know and that
started happening regularly in all sorts
of different ways so I was like
answering all these emails as best I
could because you know
this is what I'm most fascinated in the
why and figuring out what is Meaningful
and the reason behind the reason if you
will and eventually it's like well maybe
a book would be a better way better
medium of sharing this part of the
methodology the thing that for me is at
the heart of it the why you know
and yeah so we start shopping around a
book and
what did that process look like
which part the book deal getting process
I mean it was a really wild ride
um
bullet Journal I was really I was really
blessed with a lot of attention for this
thing right and I didn't really know
what to do with it and eventually agents
started reaching out to me it's like
have you thought about a book
and that's not something that happens to
a lot of people and I'm like I have
but I don't know if I need an agent or
something like that and all of a sudden
publishing companies start reaching out
to me and then I start going into
publishing companies and they're like
blah blah blah blah blah you know here's
a deal or here's something else I'm like
I need an agent like I don't know if
this is a good deal I don't know what
I'm getting into and it was like the
first time where it's like I really need
help because for me what was most
important about the book is that it
could serve as many people as possible
like that was it like I wanted to create
something that would help that was it
that was the goal it's like right the
best book you can to help as many people
as possible and then that became the
guiding rule for all this stuff like it
wasn't about being a bestseller it
wasn't about anything else like create
the best tool you possibly can just on
that note that seems awfully altruistic
I I find that with with my own
motivation they're often muddied with a
bit of yeah I want to help people but
like being a best at it would be cool
like what was that
and balancing the the selfish motives
with the service motives I guess for you
well I mean look
of course I would have to be able to
feed myself in the process so it wasn't
but the best seller thing I you know
my father's an author so I grew up
around like the whole idea of best
sellers and books and everything like
that and it to me it always seemed
really dangerous to
focus on something that's so out of your
control yeah
so that's something that I kind of put
out of my mind because it's it's what do
I do with the best seller part like what
what does that mean it's like a six-pack
thing you put six packs in that one yeah
like what's the underlying thing that's
trying to serve right you know like
would it be nice absolutely I'm not
gonna throw it out the window or
anything if it happens great but what's
to me just like getting to the Finish
Line with writing this book is it was
much more important and doing it in a
way where I could like this is the best
I can possibly do that was enough in
some ways it's not necessarily altruism
it's like setting the bar so low that I
can actually do it it's like I just want
to do the best job I possibly can and
finish this thing like so
you know and hopefully it helps people
that's that's all if I can do that then
great so it's it's more about the maybe
more of a survival mindset like I just
want to do a good job I know what you
mean yeah I find that anytime I'm
sitting down to write whenever I have
the best set of list in my mind it just
completely takes the fun out of it but
whenever I think you know what I just
want to write something I'm proud of
that can help at least one person
suddenly the bar is low it's like I
could write something I'm proud of yeah
and I was I was chatting to Cal Newport
on the Pod a few weeks ago and he said
every single time he's written a book
he's told himself this one just needs to
be reasonable the next one is going to
be good
I I love that just like lowering the bar
just needs to be reasonable yeah I think
lowering the bar is is an incredibly
powerful mindset really it's like as
long as you keep making progress I
actually got this from Austin Cleon I
was on his newsletter or I read his
newsletter rather and he talked about an
author's name I'm forgetting right now
who had a card that's uh without hope
without despair every day and like that
was the writing process for me without
hope without disparity just right that's
it and it worked you know it's a sat
down it's like I don't feel like it just
right yeah well it's gonna be great yeah
that's it and it's
I don't know my kind of my productivity
ethos is like do the thing that you
committed to regardless you know like
some maybe I'll get more done maybe
you'll get less done but just do it show
up so how did you like which publisher
did you go with in the end hanging
around the house oh nice same
um how do you decide on them I mean I
guess it's easy enough because they're
big but like what were the the imprint
that I went with was portfolio and I had
published a bunch of authors whose work
I liked a lot and Seth God and Ryan
holiday those kind of things like okay
they get it they get my space and I
think they know what I'm trying to
accomplish with this like this the book
for me is a tool really it is and I was
trying to figure out who would
understand that and I felt like that
very much was the case they understood
what I was trying to do and you know uh
yeah they they clearly represented
people who's thinking I also
very much enjoy so then you had a
deadline how did you deal with the doing
the work when there is a deadline and
writers famously procrastinate all the
time yeah
um like you know it took me a year to
write this thing on and off but I also
designed it so it was like a two-part
peace
for me I think the big mistake I would
say is that I felt like writing was just
going to be a thing right you just sit
down and you write this thing but I felt
like for me my book was more I ended up
being more like a child that grows right
so at the beginning it's an infinite
doesn't know what it is you know it's
like crying all the time you don't know
what you're doing as a parent but then
as you keep writing and you have a
strategy for that like you quickly have
to develop a strategy for that and it's
like just growing up and then all of a
sudden it becomes like a toddler and
that has different circumstances it
starts like understanding things at a
little bit of a direction it's like
running around then it becomes an
adolescent where it's disagreeing with
you and then like you need a completely
different approach and how you write so
I mean the short version of this is that
it went from something that was really
creative which required like one
approach to something that was much more
editorial like for in general the way
that I write is I put way too much stuff
on and then I just like it's more of a
sculptural approach like way too much
content and then scrape away everything
you know just leave what's necessary
it's like Anne Lamont you know it's like
I just write a terrible first draft and
I'm okay with that yeah I I got to that
point in my career I guess maybe as a
designer and just like get it up and and
then worry about it worry about it later
and I feel like that that was really
helpful because I'm like oh wow this
really is bad yeah it's truly bad but
this paragraph and this sentence are
something yeah yeah that's the stage I'm
at right now I've done the shitty first
draft and I look at it I'm just like
most of it is really bad but okay
occasionally there are some bits that
are reasonable and I'm like all right
cool how do we get just more of those
bits yeah string them together
so my process was very different
depending on what stage I was at in
writing the book but I also handed off
pieces of the book early so like I would
hand off like the first third and while
they were editing it I was writing like
the second third and then I give them
that back and so it was very cyclical I
was always in some different phase of
writing
which was helpful to me and I know that
every writer kind of has a different
process
how much um I I guess you would have
figured out the terminology and the
language and stuff beforehand but
possibly not because the thing I'm
struggling with right now is
title subtitle hook elevator pitch like
what is the one line two line three line
description like a thing of what is the
book about and I'm just like oh my God
why is it so hard to condense
an idea into just like a few things like
how how was that for you I mean that's
the hardest part right what's the famous
line I've had more time I would have
written you shorter letter yeah yeah I
mean for me I will say I did have the
name already it was like the bullet
Journal method like what is this like
it's very important for me that people
realize that it is a method it's not a
notebook we happen to use a notebook so
it's like the bullet Journal method the
the trouble was distilling the subtitle
and for that we actually did user
testing I had like I don't know 12
different subtitles and which do people
respond to what was the subtitle you
went with in the end
um track the past order their present
design the future
nice
if if someone were to ask you what is
the book about
what's the yeah what's your answer
it's Friday now now I I need to figure
out a one-liner with this it's like
how to live an intentional life like
that's it that the whole thing of the
bullet Journal method is trying to
figure out what that means to you and
how to embody the your values and how
you do that every day and you get to
learn more about yourself
I guess I could keep on putting a
comments
but yeah it's a systematic approach to
living an intentional life
um we've talked a bit about this idea of
values and everyone says this and I
can't figure out your values and like
live an alignment with your values and
stuff sure I have tried about five dozen
different exercises on the internet
around how to figure out your values I'm
curious how you approach that how should
one figure out their values or how how
do you how did you go about it I think
it's an ongoing process right because
your circumstances change you learn new
things and your values can change I find
but I think a big part of it is by
studying your lived experience
so what have you done that has brought
you closer to the life that resonates
with you and what have you done that has
brought you further away from that right
I think a lot of values reveal
themselves and the choices that we make
and the response we have to the choices
that we make
we learn about ourselves after the fact
right people are like oh what are my
values and they see this list of 50
values I'm like oh you know a kindness
sounds good yeah right that's like where
did kindness ever have an emotional
effect on you I'm not saying that
kindness is a bad value but is it an
actual value of yours like values I
think are something that
are very individual and something that
isn't obvious to us all out of the time
but by studying our lived experience
they can reveal themselves you know some
people who think power is a value it's
like is power of value or do you value
control and is that actual value or is
that some kind of coping mechanism does
that make sense it's it's so well like
what do you mean by value like but like
most people would probably say that yeah
I I value kindness I value honesty
integrity and stuff are we talking like
what are moments in your life where you
felt the most you like you were doing
something meaningful and trying to get
stuff out of that or to me I think it's
both sides of the spectrum it's figuring
out what moments in your life have felt
more most meaningful or more meaningful
or meaningful at all it doesn't need to
be most meaningful and what Behavior or
value supported that experience
that to me is really interesting like
what about this felt meaningful to you
yep and then you have the flip side of
that where you feel terrible about
something and like what value was not
being met or what anti-value if you will
are you
you know now embodying right is it
jealousy is it anger is it you know
pettiness that kind of thing okay so
what's the opposite of that if you don't
want to feel this way
it reveals what you do want to feel
that kind of thing and
for me embodying your values is
critical that helps you form your
intentions because values are there's no
they're kind of part of the infinite
game if you will right they like it's
something that you embody you have the
choice to embody your value or not but
only when you're aware of them it's like
you have choices how to respond again we
get back to stoicism here right the only
thing you control is how you respond
okay so what's driving that response
you know that that's the part that like
is missing off and it's like okay I have
a choice as to how to respond but then
what's driving that choice
and that choice I would like to argue
should be your value because if there's
nothing behind
the choice then you might be responding
poorly
so are we are we talking sort of general
or almost like your own personal or ten
commandments type thing
or that's one way of looking at it sure
I think it's
embodying qualities that
help you find meaning in some ways
right it's like when I'm being this way
it feels meaningful when I'm not being
this way yeah it does not so like for me
when I'm teaching someone something that
I know it feels very meaningful
um when I am being like when I feel like
I'm being authentic and honest it feels
meaningful when I have to tell a white
lie it feels really bad
when I don't give someone all the
information because it might make them
feel bad or something like oh I'm almost
like something about this feels really
off sure and
is that kind of what we mean what we
mean like so sort of figuring out what
are yeah sort of almost like taking your
feelings about stuff seriously and
figuring out okay what therefore are
like what does this reveal about the
things that I value yes that's exactly
right and I think that that's
an ongoing process yeah and then
you try to figure out ways to embody
those values right and I feel like
there's also different value domains as
well like you're not going to have the
same values at work as you are you know
at home you know you your your partner
doesn't need the best boss like that's
not that's not a value that's meaningful
there and so you can start to like
quantify where you're
now qualify where your values are yeah
in which domain and that a big part of
that is just like studying your life
it's like okay I felt badly about doing
this thing why
and the answer isn't always obvious I
would argue the answer is not obvious
and over time you start to observe
patterns in your own behavior like huh
when I spend time with this person
things feel good or if I feel really
connected or I feel very authentic
why why does this person bring that out
of me what do we discuss what do we do
and then people who don't like every
time I spend time with this person I
feel completely drained or I feel like I
betrayed myself or you know I'm trying
to put on a show or I don't feel good
and then you can start like unraveling
that whole Rabbit Hole one piece at a
time and it words come up like you
actually have language here you know
authentic inauthentic present distracted
these kind of things and curious for me
you know value mind is curiosity and
play those are two things that are how
do I bring play into the situation
you know how to embody curiosity in this
situation like I have an option of how
I'm going to respond here and how do I
bring that up
nice
um
what's your take on
three-year planning five-year planning
10-year planning one-year planning like
having heard all the zillions of stories
from people like what have you seen it I
guess in your life and in the lives of
people who've reached out to you with
stories what's what's a good amount of
planning versus spontaneity to her yeah
I mean for me
I guess I approach this whole thing
differently because for me it's more
about being in the present right and
trying to develop different goals that
are for me experiments their plays if
you will it's okay what am I going to do
now that helps me embody this value in
some way
and
A Five-Year Plan doesn't really work
that way because I know it's going to
change that being said
kind of having an idea of where I want
to head like okay so I think the best
way I can talk about this is that
I I have this analogy that goals are
like lighthouses oh right tell me more
sure so a lot of times when I heard
about goals in the past it's like here
is your target yeah right and
that's how I operated and it was always
disappointing and confusing at least for
me and the reason why is when you set a
goal you're setting it at the furthest
distance away from that reality from day
one is the first distance you'll ever be
away from that goal so it means you
don't know anything about that
experience you don't know anything about
that reality and every day as you get
closer to that goal it becomes clearer
and it becomes more real
and oftentimes you change your mind
you're like oh wait this is not what I
actually want or you learn something new
it's actually over here so I think that
rather it being the Final Destination
it's like a lighthouse and from what I
understand of lighthouses I'm a
lighthouse expert but let's just go with
it for now you never go to the
lighthouse right the lighthouse stands
at a place that's actually really
hazardous it's there to make sure the
chips don't go there but ships can also
use it to navigate
and I think that that's a really
interesting way of thinking about your
goals because it's you're setting some
destination for you to learn about
something along the way and if you think
about it as a lighthouse then going off
course or you know changing course if
you will is part of it right and you
just keep on setting different
Lighthouse goals okay it's like
I want to be this kind of doctor and
then you get halfway through and you're
like oh actually no it's like this
specialty or this thing or actually
something completely different that I
didn't know about at the beginning of
the journey so I like lighthouses to
come back to the year-long five-year
goals
I think it's the same kind of thing if
you believe in something strongly and
it's going to take you five years start
right and then change your mind when you
when it becomes more real I think having
objectives is really important right but
I also think abandoning the objectives
based on realities just as important
if that makes sense like when when a
theory starts becoming very real through
your lived experience
that's that's
and then resetting along the way I don't
know for me everything is a lot more
organic than setting five-year goals
like sometimes I want to do something
like that's going to take five years
let's start and see what happens and
then I'm not like doggedly pursuing this
thing for five years because I've never
been in a situation where five years
later I'm the same person that just
hasn't happened for me
it's good to have the direction so I'm
don't get totally lost right yeah like a
lighthouse but along the way I'm just a
completely different person
that's a really great way I think about
golf I love it that's fantastic yeah I
think there's a lot of um almost
moralizing around this around how it is
a morally good thing for you to stick to
the goal that you set and like if you
move the goal posts that's like
considered a bad thing rather than a
good thing that you move the goal post
and often people will like I get I get
this criticism from my mum quite a lot
they're like hey so you know that time
you were taking those exams to do
residency in the US like what happened
to that and I'm like why'd you move the
GoPro and she's like yeah you know you
move the goal post I'm like yeah exactly
I started doing the thing realized that
that's not in fact the person I want to
be and change my mind
and I feel like this is probably a good
thing rather than a bad thing but I
guess it's that balance between
being a quitter versus being someone who
changed their mind on goal as they got
more data how how do you think about
that balance sure yeah and there's
there's no ultimate answer to that as
well I feel like one easy way to define
the difference or the distinction there
is that you continue making progress
towards something right rather than like
this target you're like okay it's over
here and you continue to work and like
it's going to take two months it's gonna
take like the book that I started to
write and the book that I handed off are
completely different things right I did
the work it took the time but
the goal and the destination were very
different from one another if that makes
sense and then just giving up sure and I
don't think that that's necessarily a
bad thing either
um there's a lot of nuance here that I
can't really like cover but there's one
thing where it's like you just don't
believe in this anymore
and that's okay you know and
sometimes you don't believe I mean don't
get me wrong I didn't believe in my book
on multiple days in those years right
it's like why am I doing this like I got
no business doing this all these things
but it would go away and there's a
season for that but if like you truly
just don't understand why you're doing
something anymore you know
then quoting is absolutely okay you know
we have such limited time here
I think it's understanding why you're
quitting specifically
that's important what about this isn't
working for me and oftentimes like
it not meaning anything to you anymore
now that you realize what the truth
about this goal is
is really important you know it's it's
um
it's a process and a lot of times we set
goals that actually seem quite pointless
halfway through you're like wait a
second not because it's hard the
hardness shouldn't be the determining
factor it's kind of like I don't know
what value this is adding to my life in
case like you know it's it's is this
going to make me a better partner a
better teacher a better whatever like
you're halfway through do you feel that
way
you know the reality is starting to set
in
you know and if the answer is no yeah
ongoingly then I think that's a pretty
good indication that that might not be
worth pursuing
and so one of the things we did this
time last year actually when we first
moved into the studio was you know
worked with a business coach and he
talked about kind of making uh sort of
three or three year picture three-year
plan kind of thing
and I was like oh come on like three
years social media space things changed
a lot and it was like you know that's
fine but it's useful to think at this at
this stage what do you just like imagine
that through your picture to be because
then we can start working towards that
and see what happens another time I was
like okay three years from now I want to
be doing on a 10 million Revenue I want
to be a team of 40 people like physical
location in London like multiple Studios
where we can like bring our YouTuber
Academy students in and rent them out
and stuff
and we're like all right cool let's
start working towards that thing that
that kind of picture
and
within probably about six or so months I
started feeling hmm that picture no
longer feels great like I actually don't
want to have a team of 50 people and be
worrying about Revenue numbers and be
trying to rent Studio space to people
there's like that seems like the worst
thing in the world okay uh and then that
Vision changed and it became much more
about like
actually it'll be quite nice to be able
to focus on doing things I actually
enjoy which is Reading Writing and
teaching without having to worry about
managing a team and all that kind of
stuff
and so having and and this is why we
only signed up to this studio space for
a year because I knew at the time it was
like okay this is an experiment we're
going to gather data throughout this
year and see what happens so now we're
as of like tomorrow we're and next week
we're moving out of this place
um I'm moving into a flat with my with
my brother and his wife and we're kind
of building a YouTube podcasting studio
in the flat to see what that will be
like and again that's just an experiment
for a year to see what happens and I
find that sort of being
committing to a path for a certain
period of time just to sort of not be
too uh not having a Direction but also
being completely open to changing my
mind on it because knowing that like hey
I actually have no data points on this
let's just gather data treat it as an
experiment and see what happens yeah I
totally agree with that path I mean it's
like you know when you keep on working
right you're pushing things forward and
as you learn I think it's silly to
continue to go towards something when
you realize that it's not aligned with
what you care about especially
because you're experiencing it every day
I mean with the story it sounds like you
did the work things came up you learned
and it didn't feel right and then you
opted to do something else it wasn't
like pulling the plug so that goal
became irrelevant at that point I do
think it's helpful to start somewhere
though like to be very clear it's like
let's create the three year let's create
the five year
for me again it's always comes back to
the value it's like okay the value
determines the goals like I want to
create a really wonderful company how do
I do that in five years and then like
we'll learn yes it's great you know just
more playful I think you just need to be
much more playful in our productivity
it's like okay
playful productivity yes now
um I was going to call my book playful
productivity or joyful productivity or
something annoyingly both those names
are taken by other people that have made
blogs there with those titles damn
um
the changing gear is a bit sure
bullet Journal has an app what's what's
a deal with that sure
um
so for me people always ask me like
digital or analog and I'm really
agnostic to this it's about the finding
the best tool for the job when it comes
to Bujo I find that a notebook at least
to me and many is really helpful because
it helps you go offline but it also has
limitations that are unnecessary right
like a notebook's not going to remind
you to check in with it
and technology is really good like that
and having been a ux designer and
designing apps all my life like I really
enjoy doing that as well I'm like huh
how can I Bridge the digital analog in
different ways and the app is like that
it sets reminders it helps you track how
often you've reflected to keep you
honest about it it gives you different
quotes it allows you to take pictures of
your notebook so you can have a digital
backup you know all these
tools that can be really helpful to
people you don't need it I see all of
the products that I make as accessories
to the methodology you know but uh yeah
I try to fill my own gaps in my
productivity system like okay I actually
want to take a picture of this to send
it to somebody
I want to have a backup of it like I
lost a lot of my notebooks in a flood
early on so like I and that's a real
thing yeah so the app does that kind of
thing it's it doesn't replace the
notebook it's an extension of that's why
it's called the companion app yeah yeah
no just looking up on the on the App
Store um plus it's also a Nexus for
information I mean one thing again I'm
really blessed that
bullet Journal has blown up but it's
gotten so big that people really kind of
lose lose the signal the noise
and so the affirm is also a Nexus like
here are all the Articles you know
here's how you can begin all that stuff
in your pocket and it's easy you know
for like three bucks or something yeah
it's it's a good place to start
being intentional about how the
information is surfaced okay so like one
one question I've been asking a few
guests is that
um let's say you won the lottery and you
don't have to worry about money ever
again
and you've got to do something with your
time
how different does that look compared to
what you're doing now with your time
does this basically just mean that I
don't have to work if I don't want to or
is it what do I do with my resources uh
basically you don't have to work if you
don't want to okay yeah we want to make
sure that we're playing the right game I
try to find the question to make that
more obvious yeah yeah
um
I did the same thing
for sure yeah and that's the biggest
change in my life people is like how did
bullet Journal link change your life
it's like I wake up every day and I know
exactly what I why I do what I do and I
believe in it doesn't make it easy no
not at all it's really hard and I have
really bad days and I have to wear all
sorts of hats that don't fit really well
yeah but it's like I know why and that's
the shift and like I want everybody to
experience what that's like
I think it's available to more people
than people would imagine right like
just being really deliberate about the
choices that you're making and taking
ownership about those choices
of those choices
I love it
um so how does bullet Journal evolve
from here I mean you've got the
notebooks you've got the method like
you've got the app you've got the course
the university
what else is like I'm struggling to see
what the future looks like but
presumably you're like so much stuff I
want to do but like yeah yeah education
education I think the biggest challenge
that I still face and people like what
is it yeah right and the answer that I
used to give people which I have now
understood to be unhelpful like it's
whatever you need it to be but then you
run into the blank page problem which is
you sit down and like you want to create
something with a blank page and you
don't know what to write so for me it's
about creating
educational access points where people
can see bullet journaling for students
but literally for doctors that kind of
thing showing them how they can
implement this methodology for their
circumstances specifically that's what
I'm interested in creating it's an
extension of what I was doing before
which is finding people who show you how
they use bullet journal for their
specific use case so is that and also
I mean learning how to live an
intentional life is just
I don't know it's it's an infinite topic
there's so many ways of approaching it
and it's really exciting to me so for me
it's it's it's I'm trying to create an
infrastructure for me to build the
things to build tools to help people
yeah live an intentional life and
there's just so many ways of going about
that and there's some
really interesting projects in the works
along those lines but I think it's
education I feel like education as a
company is one of our core focuses as
both a value and as a goal
foreign
I love it another thing is I don't know
where bullet Journal will go like
there's so many different ways but we
have a community and they teach me all
the time so they'll ask me questions and
they will identify opportunities for us
to like really lean into and build
systems around and all that kind of
thing so I'm really excited to learn
about what people need and see if we can
build something to support that
Ryder thank you so much it's been
wonderful uh where can people where's
the best place for people to learn more
about you about the bullet Journal
method bullet journal.com amazing nice
and easy and we'll put links to all the
stuff including the book and my video on
the topic and Matt's video on the topic
and your website and bullet journal.com
all of those links will be in the video
description and the show notes wherever
people are listening to this thank you
so much for coming on thanks so much for
having me
all right so that's it for this week's
episode of Deep dive thank you so much
for watching or listening all the links
and resources that we mentioned in the
podcast are going to be linked down in
the video description or in the show
notes depending on where you're watching
or listening to this if you're listening
to this on a podcast platform then do
please leave us a review on the iTunes
Store it really helps other people
discover the podcast or if you're
watching this in full HD or 4k on
YouTube then you can leave a comment
down below and ask any questions or any
insights or any thoughts about the
episode that would be awesome and if you
enjoyed this episode you might like to
check out this episode here as well
which links in with some of the stuff
that we talked about in the episode so
thanks for watching uh do hit the
Subscribe button if you aren't already
and I'll see you next time bye